et à 50 ans
une jeune fille
assise derrière la voiture de mon père
nous quittons la ville de yb adha
dans le ouest du nigeria
en allant vers le village ce qu'on
appelle à l'époque dit lâche
notre ville natale
un trajet peut-être de
150 km 1h30
mais un enfant
qui le garde à gauche
qui regarde à droite qui voit la beauté
les arabes les forêts les plantations
mais c'est un seul mot ça
la potion ou le moment le plus attendu
que cette fille
et ses fresques dans la voiture c'est
quand papa va s'arrêter quelques pas 10
km avant il y fait
bso d'époque urbain
ddu 20,1 vendeuse
darricau
béni dahico qu'on appelle un viol ou
d'un accord qu'on appelle ici a nommé go
qu'on appelle dans la lande
des normes
connaissez
freilich
qu'est ce qui est plus intéressant que
nous à l'époque
c'est que gamme qui vendent m'a dit ah
papa
comme y est vous voulez papa va tenir à
10 1 2 3
auquel ici
mais c'est qu'il dit pierre fascinant
non ce que la dame va couper en petits
morceaux de feuilles de banane il va
mettre chacun chacun d'eau payer un
billet doux pire donc vous avez dans vos
mères
voire petits plats
soin de banane avec vous abiquo le biais
des choses et vous mangez
tout au long de ce trajet nouvelle et
souffler les purs
parce que qu'est ce qu'on cherchait à
l'époque
une belle vie et 6 à la bellevue
la vie dure les beautés les arbres et
tout
fastweb
aujourd'hui vous prenez le même doute
pour aller dans le même ville maintenant
c'est lisible qu'est ce que vous
constatez
les générations d'aujourd'hui
ont leur place et les abris avec les
déchets pas tous
les métaux
le bâtiment - produit totalement
construire à gauche et à droite
et qu'on arrivait au même endroit où on
achète de payer s'ils sont toujours là
bas
aujourd'hui on vous aime les beignets
show dont le sachet plastique
soit c'est transparent soit sévère soit
zhenhua face et bleu mais si les déchets
c'est le plastique
et vous demander à la gamme mais qu'est
ce qui s'est passé avec le fruit de
bananes par vous dit vous était où
togaf bilancielle maintenant et donc le
coût demandait
le modèle
sachets plastiques c'est ça notre
mentalité
6 en gros nous a donnée maintenant un
échange pour le feuille de banane pour
nos feuilles les différents faits les
différents
légumes tout ce que nous faisons avec la
nature on nous a longtemps ça l'ont
placé ça avec les classiques les papiers
foued les sage et classique tout ce que
vous voyez ici
mais je vous pose la question
comment mes petits se sont déjà dit est
ce que c'est vraiment notre
compréhension de ces changements
climatiques c'est le même
qu'est ce qu'ils avaient dit pour moi
une fille de nigériens le changement
climatique né à londres où j'ai vécu
dans la neige le changement climatique
aujourd'hui à lomé
je profite de l'est de soleil
avant
aujourd'hui c'est devenu un peu précaire
tout le monde doit rentrer dans ce débat
le débat ne faut pas rester et yves ou
gens qui m'appellent et qui vont
jusqu'aux parce que moi j'ai l'habitude
du move comme celle
vous connaissez damier
à guerrier je suis amis ma famille
les femmes les hommes que nous appellons
pauvre joulaud rural vous choisi les
mots que vous verrez je dois être avec
eux pour leur poser la question
savez vous quoi vous le changement
climatique
savez-vous quoi pour vous
la fait que nous sommes en mali assez
classique ça chez classique colons vert
couleur jaune
oui c'est le sac et placez
vous voulez continuer à vivre comme ça
où vous pensez que nous pouvons faire
quelque chose pour vraiment changer
notre vie c'est ça l'accord ben moi
c'est ça et pour vous c'est quoi
anouar
démocratiser le débat
tout le monde doit être sous la halle
est tout le monde doit être conscient de
la fête pas seulement que nous entendait
aller
v10 est
mondiale mon dieu on sait qu'en période
[Musique]
comme ovi 19 vient de nous montrer
qu'en ce ciel va tomber
il va pas faire la différence entre le
riche et le feu parce que quand vous le
sable
l'environnement reste le seul bien
comment une bonne idée avant n'y a pas
un environnement pour les riches il ya
vingt numéros pour les pauvres il n'y a
pas un engouement pour les noirs je ne
sais pas qui est noir ici
y'a pas un environnement pour les blancs
nous avons tous les mêmes
responsabilités pour ce qui est des mots
vient de nous dit dieu nous a donnée
donc le changement climatique ou moins
d'équidés réelle réponse
équilibrée elle pas de r pour les
relations le pou li l'équipage ou
équipements
l'adaptabilité c'est ça le a et le
leadership c'est l'hôtel et je vous
donne un exemple parce que je sais qu'il
ya ceux qui pensent que je voulais boit
de l'eau mais pourquoi pas
ces situations a besoin des saints bois
en peau de nous
notre relation avec l'environnement
je vous explique avec ce bouteilles
d'eau
je pense bouteilles d'eau je veux ni à
boire ce qui est de nos jeux choix le
contenu
que vous voyez classique soit je le
jette dans la rue je prends l de
poubelles je le met dedans
je fais c'est qu'on nous dise des faits
essayez de ne l'utiliser
vous voyez vous pouvez a pâti de ce
goûter
clé un petit ben moody vous enlevez ce
petit plastique ici là et vous nous
coupez ça en petits morceaux et ça c'est
le métier et vous pouvez sauter sorti
une joue et ça le plus intéressant
se bouchant là nous le jet fuel ne jette
plus vous avez besoin hameau d'ombré
j'avais c'est le plus beau cadeau
matière pouvait les cadeaux que vous
avez dans vos mains ok
après jour donne une lettre
vous voyez les pneus usés
avant ça nous coûterait de la bulle mais
aujourd'hui à cause de ces quissac on
doit avoir des relations avec
l'environnement menace à prendre son
enfant si vous avez besoin des saints
l'équipe mort où l'équipage vous soyez
équipé
dans ce que vous venez le changement est
inévitable on doive changer
notre façon irréfléchie
globale à ce qu'on a fait maintenant
avec les feuilles de bananes ont pas
d'utiliser sa dont le souper mâché
transformer ces plastiques en plusieurs
choses c'est ça les novations c'est ça
que nous avons besoin et créer des
richesses pour la jeunesse africaine
l'adaptabilité
vous voyez une réalité aujourd'hui tout
le monde doit rester masqué moi même
j'avais mon masque c'est parce que je
suis beau loin de ce que j'ai enduré ce
qu'est ce qu'on nous demande aujourd'hui
d'apprendre à un moment que oui on
continue à travailler le thème mais fait
ça avec beaucoup
d'attention pour ne pas tomber dans le
même piège que
nous en fait en fait aujourd'hui vous
pouvez utiliser votre téléphone vous
pouvez utiliser le lever du soleil
imaginez là vous pouvez utiliser
plusieurs choses pour faire avancer vos
champs agricoles
mais les choses le plus important que
nos mamans c'est de la paix l'insee de
la télé que il doit être le propre été
aussi des l'homme errait il commençait
sa de ses clefs et ouvert c'est là
maintenant ils doivent les deux
coopératif
pour avoir
position juridique pour leurs terres
et enfin
le leadership
on utilise souvent
en oublions de quoi il s'agit
celui de chine
c'est un grand moment ce leadership
c'est notre capacité d devient ce
qu'est ce que on vous demande qu'est ce
que moi je vous demande je vous demande
du sud on sait que notre soin d'y
prendre une décision parce que celui de
chypre que nous avons besoin aujourd'hui
pour garder la voie et assuré que nous
enfants et nous allier enfants vont
éditer
un doublement sais
c'est de commencer
pas moi avoue
c'est normal l'autre personne qu'il doit
aller d'abord c'est moi si vous je
remercie